[Music]
every toy story fan will be pleased to
note that the franchise's fourth
installment is set to hit the big screen
in June of 2019 Toy Story 4 will make
way for a handful of new characters all
of which are as lovable as the ones who
came before them watch until the end to
find out which toy will steal the show
first time at the things don't forget to
hit that subscribe button and give this
video a big thumbs up now
let's take a peek at the new characters
that were introduced in the Toy Story 4
trailer with the way things left off in
Toy Story 3 most of us were certain that
the franchise had come to an end so
imagine our surprise when toy story 4
was announced if you're like us you're
probably wondering what plotline this
movie will follow because well we were
made to believe that our favorite toys
had completed their lifecycle but it
looks like Pixar has something else in
mind for woody in the game and we're
curious to find out what they have in
store for us
according to Toy Story 4 is latest
trailer there will be a total of three
new characters joining the production
and from what we've seen so far they're
downright hilarious so let's take a look
at the first character in the lineup
sunny little is known about the newest
addition to the Toy Story franchise but
that won't stop us from getting to the
bottom of things bunny is a blue and
green fluffy teddy bear with a whole lot
of attitude I don't care which Cabbage
Patch
you're from gave me back my viewmaster
before I knock the dimples off your face
and this is made clear from the get-go
despite being as cute as a button bunny
is full of surprises which is why the
trailer showcases him talking behind
Woody and Buzz Lightyear's back in a
short debut bunny has seen mocking
buzzes catchphrase however this doesn't
stop us from liking him the fuzzy
character is voiced by actor Jordan
Peele who's known for being one of the
most hilarious comedians on the market
he first won us over by playing various
roles in the comedy prone TV series
MADtv and now there's just no telling
how far the actor will go if there's one
thing we do know it's that Toy Story 4
will be the funny
Disney Pixar movie we've ever seen
because let's face it the cast speaks
for itself
ducky the second character to join Toy
Story 4 is none other than a plush duck
named ducky while some themes were quick
to comment on Pixar's unoriginal names
we find them to be very fitting after
all most toys are named by children and
they tend to be straight to the point
from what we gather bunny and duckies
seem to beat the best of buzz and this
is made obvious by the way they're
laughing and joking around with each
other in the trailer the yellow duckling
might seem sweet but it's never good to
underestimate new characters after all
look what happened with lotsa hugging
bear in Toy Story 3 ducky is voiced by
none other than keegan-michael key who's
Jordan peels best friend in real life
these two celebs go way back and have
acted side by side for over a decade
their chemistry is undeniable
which is why ducky and bunny seem to
feed off of each other's good humor well
there's no way of knowing if they'll
play significant roles in Toy Story 4
we'd love to see them get a good amount
of screen time for ki the Toy Story
franchise is known for its great music
amazing animation and timeless
characters so why would we expect
anything less for its fourth installment
the Toy Story 4 a teaser trailer
reunites us with both sides now a song
that's written by Joni Mitchell and
executed by Judy Collins throughout this
short trailer we see our favorite Toy
Story characters holding hands and
swaying to the music everyone in the
lineup has a huge smile on their face
that is until forky makes his grand
debut at this point it becomes clear
that forky is terrified of his newest
pals in fact he screams
before running away from woody in the
game and one glance is all it takes for
us to realize that four keys right he
doesn't belong there after all he's the
furthest thing from a toy this plastic
spork is voiced by actor Tony Hale who
is known for playing squeamish
characters like Buster Bluth in Arrested
Development much like buzz once did for
he is having a hard time accepting his
role as a toy which causes him a great
deal of stress according to director
Josh Cooley porky was created by Bonnie
who fashioned him out of a handful of
random objects for the time being fans
are led to believe that porky will be
the big bad of Toy Story 4 but whether
or not this is true remains to be seen
for now it looks like forky is nothing
more than an anxiety driven plastic
utensil whether he's good or evil we
just hope that porky realizes that he
can become whatever his heart desires
in the end toys do come in all shapes
and sizes so now that you're up to date
with Toy Story fours newest members
let's take a look at the film's plot
although little information has been
released sources state that this film
will circle around an action-packed love
story as many of you know Bo Peep is the
love of Woody's life
[Music]
however she was missing from Toy Story
three Splott lines according to the last
movies director Lee Unkrich bo-peep was
sold at a yard sale before the events of
Toy Story 3 took place this
heartbreaking revelation is what caused
writers to create the upcoming film so
basically the film's plot will revolve
around locating Bo Peep and bringing her
home to Bonnie despite having the life
you always dreamed up woody is a broken
toy without Bo peeps affection so the
gang plans a road trip with their newest
friend for ki and sets out to find Bo
Peep in the big wide world
during their travels the crew will
inevitably cross paths with bunny and
ducky and if these two are lucky they
might get invited to tag along
bringing woody and Bo Peep back together
will be a tearjerker if we've ever seen
one believe it or not but some fans were
a little upset to find out that Pixar
was coming out with a fourth choice
story movie this is because they believe
that Toy Story 3 summed up the franchise
on a high note and while they might be
right
we hope that Pixar proves us wrong by
delivering the best Toy Story movie yet
so are you eager to see the upcoming
film if so let us know which new
character you're most excited for in the
comments below and that's a wrap
thanks for watching and see you next
time on the things
[Music]